ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show i'm so sad we're leaving
afghanistan and i'm so
sad that was my first war my
first war and we are gone
just like that 21
quick ears and the bind administration
surprising us all surprise
they're doing an unconditional truth
withdrawal by september
11th wow
well we did it
we did what we had to do and um
we have a whole and we'll do it later in
the show we have an entire tribute
to the afghanistan war which was my
first war you always remember
your first war like your first kiss
like your first uh uh
i don't know asking a girl out your
first
[__] the first time that you had uh tuna
tartare i don't know but whatever you
whatever sticks out in your mind you
always remember your first war baby
now of course it could have been the
goal for but i was too young to really
understand
uh the gulf war um until years later
afghanistan was my first year i was a
11th grade uh just boy
and we were heading into afghanistan and
now i am
it's crazy to think of the amount of
changes i've gone through in my life
and the backdrop has been the
afghanistan war the war in afghanistan
and afghanistan now because of our
efforts there
is actually and this is and i thought
this wouldn't happen
i was a little bit of a skeptic but it
is a beautiful uh tourist destination
and it is going to as soon as covet
that's the problem
is kovid but when kovid is um
done uh tourists are going to flock
to afghanistan to to that to the
you know kashmir region between
afghanistan and pakistan and the
the four seasons is there there's so
many hotels going over there right now
uh and just it's going to be beautiful
and it's everything that we had wanted
which is to create this multi-ethnic
um democracy
thriving economy uh in the middle of
uh a bed of rocks that has been run by
tribal warlords for thousands of years
that is going to so it's sad
but we accomplished what we wanted to do
we got it done
it's done and as soon as i get my
vaccine passport i am headed
to [__] afghanistan
i don't even know the because this
hasn't been in the news i don't even
know the towns
anymore in afghanistan we used to know
them all the time
uh kabul kabul was a big one
kabul is the capital kandahar
yep it's all coming back missouri sharif
yeah
we used to talk about that
but kabul is the big one and that's
going to be
a hot spot as soon as we're
covered um stops plaguing us
speaking of uh coven
we went to get vaccinated uh we wanted
to get the uh
johnson johnson vaccine which i am a fan
of
because it has 66 uh efficacy which i
think is
fine i think it's fine i think you do
want a little risk
i do think you don't want and you want
to entirely
um immunize yourself from this
i think you want a little bit of sexy
kind of risk
and the jj shot uh it was not that
effective
but also
in addition to that um even though it
wasn't that effective it was also giving
people blood clots and they were
collapsing uh in parking lots
so you had that they were getting dizzy
and nauseous and then collapsing intense
because of the heat supposedly that's
what that's the party line
well it's hot that was johnson people
were literally taking and then just
collapsing
and john cena johnson's response was
well it's hot as hell
so that was their response that was
their scientific response
people get hot that was it uh i i
love that they did it at colorado and
then georgia but jonathan johnson's
response to the uh collapsing was people
going like was judging john's official
response was like
that heat's a [__] so you know
now yes it was only seven women that got
blood clots and women get blood clots
all the time they're bloody people these
women
and they they clot and yes the pill uh
and people say to me they go well the
pill has a higher incidence of women
um getting blood clots yeah well
who's for you taking that have your
babies ladies
so
um pitter patter of little feet
lovely sound so yes the the
babies or the blood clots and what is a
baby except just a blood clot then
eventually we'll steal your car
to meet his heroin dealer but so they
so we go and we we got we were gonna get
it at some shady pharmacy in tarzana
uh one of whitney cummings quack uh
doctors
uh probably the same guy that worked on
michael jackson
um is uh the same guy that uh gave
michael jackson propofol she put me in a
group text with she has all these shady
doctors you know from beverly hills and
stuff
and uh so she put me in a in a group
text with the doctor who gave michael
jackson propofol
what's his name get his name on the
doctor that gave michael jackson
propofol
yeah who is this guy because i guarantee
you this is the same person
i'd be shocked if it wasn't
i think it was let's see conrad murray
right so i'm going to group text with
conrad murray and whitney cummings
and conrad says every vial of j and j
serves five people so we have to get
five people to show up at this uh
pharmacy in tarzana california
and um
[Music]
and uh so i called dan carney
uh and and our friends devin and ida and
then of course ben
um and dan's already had covered
devon and i have not you have not i
don't believe i don't know if i have her
now we don't know
all the symptoms of covert like i have
for several hours out of each day so i
don't know what cove it is and isn't
um the only time i thought i had covered
was when i had every symptom of covert
in march
and in the shower speaking perfect
mandarin and i had a deep urge to
destroy this uh
country of entitled um soft
fatties in the shower i would stand
there and i go how
and i started doing corporate espionage
for like a week it was odd
that's the only reason that i thought i
might have have it i was just delivering
lead-based toys to orphanages
and then doing corporate espionage in my
spare time but
again that's the only time i thought i
had it that's the only time i thought i
i had it i would also speak i would
call presidency i somehow would get
through to him i don't even know how
i would pick up my phone he'd be on the
other end and we would chat
um he was very concerned about the fight
here in the kid
he always wanted he wanted to know about
that and i was like isn't that odd
but he said presidency said i'm going to
take down
america first through the la comedy
scene which i didn't understand
and then a few months later i did
presidency has a direct route to that to
a woman at the la times uh what's her
name that
journalist oh uh i don't want to get on
her bad side
who's that uh that name lauren was it uh
i don't know but whatever she writes all
the good stuff
all the salacious stuff but presidency
is funding her and she is taking down
america
through the los angeles comedy scene one
by one that's what presidency said to me
goes
one by one he said i didn't know what he
meant but now i do
and it's unfortunate for all but i don't
know if i had it and we don't know
what's going on so we go to la
and uh you know dan and and uh devon and
i to come and they all get a dinner at
nobu on my
arm of course uh you know
some of the least deserving people on
earth are shoving nobu sushi into their
mouth
uh on my arm and which is fine it's nice
too
you know it's like adopting people from
the third world country
um all of them dance from you know
outside of tampa
um you know so and then i didn't devin
we don't even know where they're from
but uh
i don't even know if she's like uh is
she even from iran
i don't even know yeah no one else yeah
no one even knows but
i i respect a grift and uh
she know anything about iran but anyway
so
we go there and we're all ready to do
the j and j
vaccine on uh what was that
tuesday tuesday we're gonna get and it's
one and done you get one shot
and listen i'm not excited about the
vaccine i'm no evangelist
for vaccines but i don't have a choice
if i want to leave this country and do
my job i don't have a choice
uh by the way folks they're not gonna
let you into a marriott without this
[__] i
probably but for me i have to get
there's no way
live nation all of these things are
coming out and going hey man if you want
to be in these larger venues
this is the deal you got to be
vaccinated so i'm like let's do j and j
because it's not effective and it's
pretend really it's not a real vaccine
it's fake
so i was like that's good it doesn't
really work and it's
fake and and it's killing women so so
many of the things i support
i love it really there's no downside to
me
it kills people i don't [__] and it's
fake and it's one shot you don't have to
go back to the pharmacy
i like it so we were all
going to do that you know and um
unfortunately a few hours before i
supposed to do that
rogan texted me like haha the johnson
and johnson vaccine
is uh being recalled or they're pausing
it
they're just pausing the j
j a few hours before
we're about to get it they pause the
vaccine
so i run downstairs
i talk to ben dan i say hey
we can't get it they're pausing
the vaccine because women
be cotton and uh
i would have loved that johnson johnson
came out just did the same thing where
they're like
it's hot i like but women are getting
classic ups yeah
it's hot out so i don't know what the
hell they're going to do with all the
rest of the johnson johnson vaccine
probably throw it in the street
like they did to the french wine after 9
11 after france had you know said some
uh insensitive things so after 9 11
people were pouring french wine in the
street
uh i imagine that'll be the johnson
johnson vaccine just vials of johnson
and johnson being thrown
into the street but i don't know i don't
know
how about we give it to the cops what if
we give the j
to the police
and go hey whatever happens happens but
you guys are not too
popular right now so let's collect the
members of society that aren't too
popular and give them the johnson
johnson
let's give it to the cops how about that
sex offenders let's inoculate pedophiles
with the j and j
why not jj the official vaccine of
pedophiles
teachers that have [__] their students
lineup you're getting j j
matt gates people like that shady uh
politicians get the j we've got a lot of
doses of j
now we need to decide who gets it okay
derek shovin jay and jay you get the j
congratulations you get the johnson and
johnson
you're not getting that pfizer no you
get the jnj
so then ben got on his phone and found
an appointment for me of course he made
it look a lot harder
than it was and he made it seem like he
spent a lot more time doing it now tell
us how much time you you spent doing it
in actuality in actuality probably about
an hour of an hour
okay but that was of course you said two
hours you've said an hour and a half
you've been all over the map
i think i i think i over exaggerated i
said about an hour and a half yeah
and what did you you did get me the
point which i appreciate
to get to pfizer and i show up
we got to drive to santa clarita
which is good because that's where my uh
business manager lives uh who is
homeless
so we we meet up with him for a nice uh
mexican restaurant
lunch which is lovely but before that i
got the pfizer
i go in and there's a cute little
mexican lady sitting there
first of all i walk in they go what's
your eligibility criteria i'm like
bmi [__] shut the [__] up you just want
me to say it
you know the deal i should have taken
the lizard flute and be like
you know that my [__] criteria now i
told him and dan they got a lie they got
to say they had cancer
asthma [__] like that [__] i will pop
and lock it right now
and and twerk my fat ass on your [__]
table
you do not need to ask me my criteria
do you do do you insult everyone like
that
what's your eligibility cri oh you want
me to say it
um so the black lady laughed there was a
white lady who asked me the question
black lady laughs i'm like bmi
obviously [__] i looked at the black
lady i was like
and she's like damn right and i'm like
i'm a thick [__] it just got crazy
and then we just started twerking you
know like they were twerking
um no that didn't happen but she did
laugh
um and then uh i went in to get it
which again i don't know what's gonna
happen i don't i don't we don't know
what's gonna happen with these things
i just know i really can't work if i
don't have it so i sit down there's cute
little mexican ladies sitting there
she's like do you have any allergies i'm
like
i don't know maybe the penicillin when i
was a kid she goes we don't know what's
in here she literally looked at me
holding the syringe and goes we don't
know because we don't know what's in
here
we don't know and then she smiled
so i said all right she goes we don't
know if you're allergic to it or not so
i said sure
and then she stuck me with it and then
they make you sit
uh for 15 minutes
in case you have an allergic reaction
and they have to uh cover it up
they make you sit there for 15 minutes
in case you start convulsing you have to
hide it from the media
so i sit there for 50 minutes with him
and dan
and wait for it i waited for it i'm like
wait for it
nothing and i get my second shot in
three
weeks now of course the pfizer guys are
already out in the news gun you
need another one you need more 12 months
yeah every year
but then we're gonna start to forget
like you do it for the first year and a
half and then you go [__] that [__]
i've never gotten a flu shot you got
we're done with that hey enough of that
you know
i just want to hear more of dan crenshaw
don't you
i would hear more of him
uh lena weith is in trouble because she
just uh
she made a thing for hulu called
them which is literally just
slave porn um
the episode i watched titled covenant
and i uh probably turned against it this
is somebody writing
the episode returns to the very first
scene where lucky is threatened by a
white woman and
it reveals it to be a flashback from
there what follows is one of the most
awful scenes of violence i've ever
witnessed on screen
it's crazy white supremacists dump a
baby into a
case and toss it around the room until
it's bludgeoned to death was more than i
could take
and the men raped the character lucky
while they were at it so lena weith
has made this feel-good
film here or what is this a show it's a
tv show it's a tv show
lena waith and because i get it
how you get she's gone so woke that
she's made
racist porn that's really what it is
that's how woke she's become this is the
disease of uh
wokeness pushed to its logical
conclusion uh
it'll be like a guy who sat down and he
was like wouldn't this be suspicious the
guy looked like me was like
i think that it's our job to uh really
highlight so many of the horrible things
that the jewish community faced uh
during uh world war ii
so the new the show is called
auschwitz and we never leave the showers
we're just
in there the whole time
we don't there's no character
development outside of it
and then they go well you don't think
that's a little i go no no no
the camera is actually mounted to the uh
ahead of the shower
where the uh the cyclone b comes out
and so it's primarily uh it's that
it's eight episodes of that
and then every now and then we have a
scene of the train coming in but
primarily that
uh it's a little weird it's a little
[__] weird
i don't know people are really not happy
with this because they're
you know and black people are going hey
man we don't really want to watch this
[__]
and i don't blame them
you know i get it it's a little much
this is too violent and i'm sure listen
we know
horrible things happened uh during
slavery we get it but
this is maybe too much to watch truly
it's really
really big so i think i don't know if
lena has a comment and she commented has
she gone
has she uh responded to any of her
critics who've said this is just
truly a grotesque
see what lena has to say a lot of people
are saying lean awaits
them exploits black trauma for the white
gays i don't even know
what these things mean but i think i do
whitey's watching this
i wonder if she's responded yet i don't
think she'll respond
you don't think so i don't know what's
she gonna say
that's misconduct no i mean at the end
of the day
listen she's going to
she's going to maybe respond and say
something you know maybe she'll just
make her next thing a little
peppier maybe she'll just uh do the next
thing a little uh
you know yeah she deleted her twitter
well
yeah well don't throw an infant around a
pillowcase till it's dead
i don't know if she has any talent or
they i don't even know anymore
you know but uh i i i i
she might she might be great is she
non-binary no right i can say she
uh let me see do we know i don't want to
dead name her and get thrown off
everything here because i've
i i'm not uh i i haven't kept up with
the nasdaq ticker of people's identities
by the way it's a nasdaq ticker now you
should just watch
you know he she they them they them i
mean it's like
you can't everybody looks like she's a
lesbian great good friend
you're just a lesbo you're just a lady
who lacks
ladies and violence um
but this is true this is why i got into
the airbnb lesbians because many
lesbians have
a fetish for violence and need to be
watched
not all of them not all of them um
but many of them take a turn don't they
and this uh
this uh movie has disturbed a lot of
people
uh this film this tv show whatever none
of tv shows
who cares what it is i don't want to
watch it
again it's just how much
i mean god how much can people take out
there
it's too much
by the way you know it's funny speaking
of
film this is not a film but whatever caa
sent me a audition for the new jordan
peel movie
i'm like i said hey guys i'll pass
i kind of got into it with his wife
uh i think it'd be hilarious if somehow
i got the role
and jordan said to chelsea peretti hey
we've cast this guy tim dillon and she
just flipped out
and of course chelsea's more than
welcome to come on the program and talk
to me which you won't
but we're more than welcome to have
respectful dialogue she has no interest
in it and frankly neither do i
uh when comedy opens back up i don't
really want to see too many people
i don't care about going to festivals i
don't none of it matters we're we're
deeply fractured let's leave it that way
let's stay there how about that
let's stay there i don't need to walk
around the hyatt lobby and
have fake conversations with people that
i don't care about it's true
and if you're still doing that after
this pandemic and you still will be by
the way
because people don't learn people go i
want to go back to my garbage life
i can't wait to get back to my garbage
life and all my
meaningless interactions with people i
can't wait to do it
i just can't wait to do it people will
have learned nothing from this time
they will have learned nothing about
themselves about the government about
private business about anything they
will have learned
absolutely nothing and they will go
right back to doing whatever they do
because people
truly want to waste their time on this
planet they want to waste their time
don't get in their way the one of the
most
dangerous positions you can be in in
life
is getting between somebody and the time
they want to waste
truly internalize that listen to what
i'm telling you
people want to waste their time if you
get in the way of that
if you suggest they should do something
else they will hate you
forever they will kill you
they will lash out at you like you are
some type of
nazi risen from the dead trying to
enslave the world
if you merely lightly suggest to people
that they should not spend their entire
life on this planet completely
wasting all of their time with
meaningless horseshit
they will react like a [__] possum
with a bunch of babies in a [__]
garbage [__] you know a garbage can
that you've
shooken up they will mash their teeth at
you i've never seen anything like it
just just mildly suggesting that people
don't waste their time
because their defense is well you don't
un you don't know this
means something to me well you're insane
but you can't tell people that because
that's their argument people's argument
was this
means something to me it might not be
important to you
but it means something to me and it go
you go oh god
all right whatever just move on let
people go back to the nonsense don't
don't they and they want to they want to
they want it but
the people in my world will go back to
doing uh meaningless late night sets and
tell everybody back home they're on the
late and i go
i'm gonna be all fallen and you know
somebody on dialysis
back home goes yeah
can you help me i don't have insulin no
i get six hundred dollars after tax i
can't really help you
but and i know you can't pay your cable
but maybe you could go to ann
cheryl's house and watch it there it
should be very exciting i'm talking
about my gash
i'm talking about not getting [__]
during the pandemic
on jimmy fallon's show tonight but i'm
not even gonna say those words
i obviously it's a very coded light
touch on it
and i want you to go to ann cheryl's
because you know you've been supporting
me for 12 years
yeah and i'm 48. well i finally got
five minutes on a show no one watches
and i want everyone in my hometown to
watch it before you all die
let peop hey let him go back to it
let him go back to it that's fine
don't don't get in their way
don't get in their way don't get in
their way
piedmontese beef we had lunch with these
guys when we were in omaha and we had
one of the best lunches and i put the
picture on the instagram
um italian bread italian breed of cattle
now being raised in nebraska on our
network of family ranches this is lean
beef
that doesn't sacrifice flavor or
tenderness okay
um it's tender grass-fed grass-finished
beef it ships to all 50 states
25 off discount code is tim dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n
what's great about this is we had lunch
with these guys and
it's very tasty you'd think a lean meat
wouldn't be as tasty but it actually is
incredibly tasty
because they have the certified italian
bowl
piedmont teas that they bread um and
it's really good it works in every diet
any meat eating diet this works into
it's perfect you know if you don't want
to overload effect because with the keto
diet you don't want to overload on fat
so you would do
uh you know peed my teeth you could do a
little a nice uh truffle butter on it or
something like that right
because you're getting the fat from the
butter uh not so much from the meat if
you're doing a diet where you are
a low-fat diet it's also perfect because
you have a lean cut of meat that you can
put in a salad
or something and you're not you know
it's good for cholesterol it's good for
all that stuff there's no
negative here there's no downside it
tastes very very good and i
i was a fan of it and i was surprised at
how good it was because i was like
usually meat without that much fat
but i brought my own fat too for the
meat i brought my own i always carry fat
in my car animal fat that i used i used
whale blubber
it ships to all 50 states so the website
is www.cpbeef.com
25 off discount code tim dylan rogan
loves it i love it
we all enjoy it and i think it's smart
to get on the train
and eat that meat cpbeef.com
why are you laughing i'm not we're
allowed to have
as much fun with this ad as we want
we're having fun with that it's just
funny the website's funny
see why is it funny cp beef
what's funny about it cp oh child porn
yeah
get your head out of the gutter ben
it's an odd well it's certified
piedmontese
so just go to cp beef.com i mean
now you've this is our first ad for them
the steak is very good though
the steak is very good it's very good
yes cpb.com
it's what it is i thought you were
laughing my will blubber joke which is
funny
but you you're not even well i was
laughing at that are you flying with
whale blubber like
this is the cheap joke you liked 25
off discount code tim dillon ti-mti llon
thank you
this spring as you get back to the
outdoors to explore take bespoke post on
all your adventures with a new lineup of
essential box of awesome this is so
cool if you want you get a box every
week or month what is it
month great to get started take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box for you i
like these boxes because they're fun and
they're surprising
each box costs 45 you get over 70 worth
of stuff in there you can get everything
stuff for your home bar
grooming things hygiene cooking tools
outdoor gear
box of awesome is really cool it's is it
for men and women both men and women
anybody yeah
anybody can get it it's really great you
can get anything you want
i mean uh you know it's really cool
it's it's do you get it i get this yeah
i'm subscribed to it and what do you
like about it i like the
good so i like it all too
box of awesome it's good i like
surprises
some surprises are better than others
right
like with uh your neighbors being taken
out of his house with the hard drive you
go uh oh
that's not a good surprise but what's a
good surprise is when you get a box with
a shaving tool
and a little uh martini shaker
box of awesome.com enter the code tim
dillon at checkout this is a great thing
if you really want to get some of the
amazing cool gift
perfect gift box of awesome.com tim
dillon 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com
listen this adam toledo thing is really
really disturbing this young
kid who has a few wacky nicknames
uh andy no but what are andy knows
nicknames how about
that andy knows that the guy
uh the asian guy who keeps going into
antifa rallies and uh
you know with like a nazi armband and
starts like twerking and then they beat
him up and then he
puts his face everywhere
uh so andy no has said that uh
deceased teen adam toledo his friends
referred to him as little homicide and
baby diablo
well so what it doesn't matter
he dropped the gun and then he put his
hands up and the cop shot him
the cop said drop the gun he dropped the
gun he put his hands up and the cop shot
him
we understand he didn't win the spelling
bee
we get it andy no
we understand this kid was not an
honorable student we get it he didn't
come from the best home
we get it we understand that
cops have to
understand that there's gonna be blow
back
when people see a video of a child with
his hands up being shot
it doesn't matter that the kid was uh
called baby diablo
i mean we're we're making this kid into
osama bin laden now
that's what we're gonna do they called
him
little homicide what
was he just running through the streets
of chicago just wasting people
how many cops did he kill how many
people did baby diablo
whack he's a young
mentally challenged kid with no guidance
in his life
okay and other older members of the gang
exploited him and brought him out
and you know more about this case than i
do
now is this true and i don't know if
this is true because
why are you laughing i didn't say i'm
talking about something seriously
i'm cheating you're you're making it a
joke and it's not a joke
okay i'm not here to joke around okay i
heard
i heard
i heard that he was dm'd by james
charles
i heard that am i wrong
i heard that
james charles dm'd him and said
what up baby diablo
i heard they call you little homicide
because you kill it
is that not true have you not heard that
am i wrong i haven't heard that am i
wrong
well tell us about the case then because
apparently i'm getting the wrong
information
and yet i don't think i am
so i i read that adam was in special
education i don't know if he was like
mentally challenged he was missing for
two days
his parents didn't know where he was and
he was with this guy roman who was 21.
they did a uh they shot wait a minute
he was with a 21 year old
for two days yeah named roman
do you know what i'm thinking
do you know what i'm about to say what
why don't you say it no
i don't know what you're going to say
was
can you get a photo of roman yeah i'll
show you
no i'll show you
because i've been doing work
this is a photo of roman
that's crazy
to me
all right i'm kidding
i've defended this person james charles
by the way i've said let's not jump to
conclusions
so little little diablo or is it baby
diablo
baby diablo or a little homicide or
i mean adam toledo really just something
let's call him his real name
i'm against the cops here can we just
can i say something that the advertisers
might
can we just can we just
shoot the cops that did this
no i'm serious could we let children
shoot the two cops that did it
let other children shoot the cops
they can't remove me for this because
this is my right
i'm expressing my righteous indignation
and rage
because it's woke i there is no one more
woke than myself
let's stop with showing photos of him so
roman
i was showing a picture of roman we just
did so now roman
now the problem is roman
roman is he gave him a gun
well roman couldn't have a gun with him
because he was on probation right so i
think the idea was that
he did this this car drove by he fired
eight shots at the car and then i think
he gave the gun to adam
remember when amadou diallo happened
bruce springsteen
uh did a song called 41 shots oh yeah 41
shots didn't that heal
didn't that heal what happened to that
he was a young boy riding on his back
they called him names like baby diablo
in little homicide
for these racist drunk chicago pigs
bacon the smell of bacon in the air
chase him down and out why are you
chasing anyone down an alley
let him go
[Music]
he's not gonna shoot the obamas
who cares he's gonna shoot another
diablo or a little homicide
he's gonna shoot little bullets
or little knives
i'm just saying i'm kidding
yes you should protect the poor from
each other apparently
but do you see my point are we still
even broadcasting are we still on this
i kind of went off of this we're never
monetized so i want to go somewhere else
oh we're definitely not get i think you
talked about the vaccine in the first
four minutes we're not getting monetized
on this we gotta go
if you've got a service you want us to
come over there you gotta you gotta
spend a little money
but i will go on another service
100 straight up we'll call it
little podcasts
and [__] andy no too i don't you know
what do you want me to say
[__] him i'm sick of him sucks he's i'm
sick of him
he goes in the middle of like a
tifarelli just starts twerking
in like a nazi costume from the cabaret
and then he's like they were very
angry with me they were mean to me
well stop twerking what is the
resolution
to cop violence oh um
well should i finish tell it that people
know what happened yes
yes so they ran down the alley uh adam
you've got a big head now because joe
rogan's like
her mom well tim is my mom but bill bird
does it on his own but tomorrow
well we've got a better show
than bill burr's show it's ours is
better whatever can you
get what are we gonna do we're supposed
to worship all these people to the 98
i'm a [__] and if i had the amount of
[__] in my throat that other comics
have
about their betters or their peers i
would really be gay
like the amount the [__] never leave
these people's throats about just your
struggle like
everyone's talking about how good and
but i appreciate what joe said about us
it was very nice
but enough already with everybody you
know we get it everyone's great but
our show is better than the monday
morning podcast he's a better stand-up
to me unquestionably
our show is better that is a fact do you
disagree i agree
and he's the great girl one of the
greatest stand-ups ever much better than
me but
um well you know whatever it's
me is much better but i i was i was kind
of walking back
listen all the respect to him he's a
genius he's the greatest
our podcast is the best thing out there
so
just don't even mention us in the same
name with
other of these people unless they're
willing to get in the weeds with little
harm
because i'm ripping a little harm right
now and no one is
i'm repping the man [__] these [__]
take laurie lightfoot
and get her out of there
not violently not violently
not violently just respectfully
get her out of there
will you tell people what's happening
please and stop
being nervous all the time yeah yeah so
then
they're getting chased they push down
roman another cop jumps on him that cop
keeps running
towards adam adam throws the gun behind
the fence to kind of do like
to do roman a solid it looks like and
then as soon as he turns around and puts
his hands up
he gets shot right and then goes down
dies
so and then they were saying well andy
knows what's different
andy noah has a different version of
this
andy knows version of this is that
adam was in antifa
and they were planning on destroying
the white house and he was running to
the white house
and the cops and he actually
had a direct energy weapon adam he had a
direct energy weapon
that he was using uh to destroy the city
of chicago
and he also had him there was at poor
andy no i don't know if this is true
adam had summoned a massively big
marshmallow man to walk through
chicago and destroy it
and there was a dog and a refrigerator
and there was something called
zul but again this is andy knows
journalism
and he knows journalism
andy knows journalism is that there was
a river of slime
running under chicago pulsating with
people's negative emotions and thoughts
i'm trying to do this i want the cops in
uh the clink not good
they slandered his name for a week too
they're saying he had a gun in his hand
when he was shot
clearly not true they're saying that
they all lie over there rahm emmanuel
laurie lightfoot what does that even
mean that named lightfoot
a weird name from like the lord of the
rings
bilbo baggins and nori lightfoot
you know she's samwise gamgee and lori
lightfoot
what are we talking of yes she dressed
up like the covet destroyer right
right covid yeah that was it so stupid
the rona destroyer
so just i'll fix you we get a better one
i kind of do i respect that a little bit
what if she did that what if she comes
out in that
to deal with the cops
hey if she comes out here's the thing
i will turn completely for lori ledford
if she comes out dressed like the
riddler
and she just deals with the cops in that
manner
what happened with this thing this is
gonna be uh but there weren't a lot of
riots right people are i didn't see any
riots no
there there's gotta be something done
here you can't get rid of all cops
because then crime's just gonna go
through the roof but like
i don't know can you stop these people
that are like
idiots from becoming what about kim
potter yeah i was gonna
see if kim potter you want to play this
i can't what is it i don't want to see
this again okay
i don't want to see a guy getting shot
again we're trying to do it listen this
is a comedy podcast that talks about
real [__]
i don't want to start doing torture porn
this i'm not lena waist i think this was
about
uh kim potter specifically oh yeah well
then let's watch that
i haven't seen this yet
26-year veteran of the force is now
charged with
second-degree manslaughter and has been
arrested
[Music]
so
it's my belief that the officer who'd
ever had the intention to deploy their
taser
but instead every cop
look look at how close his eyes are i
know every cop looks there's a real
problem here
you know what it is it's not a great job
most people are figuring out ways to not
be cops
and i think the people that are becoming
cops it's really not the it's not the
best and the brightest
yeah what what were you giving a face to
earlier on in the video there's like an
edm
drop for when it's like yes yes well you
got to keep people into it
you got to keep people into it you got
to keep people into it no matter what's
happening
you need an idiot the strong's kind of
dope as [__] can you keep playing it
yeah yeah yeah
you're right with a single bullet
the song is dope as [__] oh and they're
sampling
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah i mean can someone get this [__]
out of here too put her in jail
kim potter her name she should be in
jail
kim potter stop hiring these substitute
teachers they're giving them guns
this woman should have been teaching
health
not even a real thing you gave her a gun
that's a good idea huh yeah i look at my
aunt kathleen i go you know what she
needs a weapon
here's what the cath needs here's what a
middle-aged menopausal woman needs a
weapon
and it's not all it's not all gendered
but there's a lot of women out there
that agree with me
that's the reality
there's certain jobs women should not do
there's a few jobs women shouldn't do
president
senator congressman cop doctor
lawyer fire department banking
financial tech math higher education
uh any education above third grade
uh a chef a manager of a hotel
ceo or cfo ceo cio of a company
investing vc venture capital
driving driving ubers lifts cabs
um working at uh aquariums or zoos or
hotels entertainment
you know and then there are things that
women are perfectly suited to do like
um the dear abby column remember people
would ask her advice and she'd write
she'd be like dear dear lovelorn in
oklahoma
i understand what you're saying but in
all seriousness
you know there are you know we got to
watch them a little you got to watch
from these ladies
am i wrong i'm not trying to sound
misogynistic here
he's the gay misogynist
but there are there's certain kim
potter sh didn't know the difference
between
the gun and the taser
is that a problem
is that an issue
i'm asking
how about
and if if you're gonna have cops you
need them to be
real lesbos big bull dykes big
because they have a sense of justice
that i don't always agree with
but kim potter i believe can we find out
she's a heterosexual before i make this
point
but i believe kim potter
husband yeah she's got a husband this is
a problem
you need you need a lesbo as much as it
pains me to say it
and as much as they've given me a lot of
hell over the last year
you need lesbian and not those lipstick
lesbians in the desert you need a real
hulking just like if you wanted to
interior design a house you wouldn't
bring in me
you bring in a real gay person like a
real gay guy
who was like really gay and got it when
you have a woman cop she needs to be a
real
lesbian like like a barn raising dikes
on bikes
lesbo because that then men will respect
her
no one respected this woman so she had
to try to be cool and shoot people
with uh you know she didn't do she's uh
she didn't know the difference between a
her gun and a hot glue gun
she should be teaching a second grade
class this is what kim potter should be
doing all the kids come to the come to
the
and remember they would get the
parachute and you put the balls in the
middle of the parachute and you go like
this and then the balls go in the air
that's her job not uh shooting people
and and who's her husband god he's
jeffrey potter is he a cop toe
uh jeff worked as a detective
i don't know maybe one person should
should not maybe like you can't be
allowed to have two cops
in in love cop love
cops need to go back to when it was new
york undercover look at the show new
york undercover
because it was a black guy and a
hispanic guy and a tough talking latina
uh chief and that worked look up new
york undercover
lauren velez malik yoba
oh patty de urbanville is the chief yeah
get this
patty there we go yeah she was the chief
and she made sure everything was fair
god is she better off she looks good
she was the chief mm-hmm and then there
was malik yoba
and and michael dilorenzo
and lauren velez they were all
detectives
and then the lieutenant was uh this
woman kim potter it looks like actually
but i don't know what to do
anymore with what's going on with the
the cops it's
very bad
i don't know anymore what to do i just
don't know
i think that you have to stop
letting this psych evaluations for these
people have got to be
much better some of these cops to psych
evaluations do you even know how bad
they are
some of these cops psychopath the first
question on it is who do you want to
shoot the most
that's not good they go who what race do
you want to shoot the most
that's the cop evaluation here's another
question they go
if a cop in your vicinity shoots a baby
will you plant a gun on that baby and a
lot of them go
yeah that's that's question two
question three is how many people are
you comfortable shooting a day
and if you answer below 10 you don't get
the job you have to say 10
plus i am comfortable discharging my
weapon
into 10 plus people a day no matter what
are you scared all the time
yes i'm terrified of everything
how many anxiety disorders you have four
that i've been diagnosed with
are you terrified i'm scared of
everything
all the time that's why i want to be a
cop because i'm scared
good we like fear are you scared enough
to make something
happen yeah
be scared shoot first make things up
later
they interview people for the lapd
they're like how proud are you
to be a member of one of the most
corrupt police forces in the history of
how proud are you
and yes there's good cops and they get
in [__] situations and bad stuff happens
but the things that are happening now
are beyond any justification it looks
like we got a bunch of
like just like weird scaredy cat
trigger happy freaks running around just
emptying guns in a p and they're like
well if i'm a cop i could get shot
yeah but you're a cop like that's part
of the game
part of the game is that you're
encountering people that are not at
their best
they're they're drunk they're on drugs
they're dangerous
they're 12. you know people when they're
at their scariest
they're toddlers literally and
you have to deal with it as a cop you
can't
always be like
you know but i get it the cops go hey
it's gonna be me or them it's gonna be
them i'm like yeah but the the guy
didn't
shoot at you and he didn't raise his gun
at you he threw the gun down and then he
raised his hands
you know
also why not shoot him in the leg no one
shoots in the leg they always go fatal
force and of course i'll have 19 people
on instagram
when i post the episode the reason
the reason i'd be kim potter the reason
no one shows a bubble
bad situations man bad situations
and not an easy fix
either
listen to this can you bring up just
scroll down a little bit
this is when the cops made sense new
york police detectives jc williams who
recently divorced cop trying to be good
father to his son
and eddie torres a young puerto rican
who struggles with his heritage try to
balance their stressful work duties with
their own personal demands
their boss lieutenant virginia cooper is
tough but
fair in her assignments that's when it
worked
that is when it worked when you had new
york undercover or you had
sippowitz on nypd blue dennis franz a
fat guy who knew he was racist and that
he should change
every episode of that show was just him
being like i'm [__] racist
and a black lady was like why are you so
damn racist
he's like i'm trying i'm sorry i gotta
do better
that's that was a good show
that was a good show because he worked
for jimmy smits who was a hispanic
gentleman
you saw how it all can work if
it can all work if you have a
multi-ethnic police force and they're
all actors
it can work if it's a television show
policing in this country can be saved if
it is on a sound stage
and it is a television show that is my
hope
if the if you get people who are
actors and give them fake guns and let
them solve crimes that were written
by people in a writer's room we can save
policing in this country it's my hope
it's my hope i don't believe we have any
hope left for real policing
but i believe we can get a killer show
let's solve this on tv
let's solve this on television
or on netflix with a show about cops
changing
reform the police on netflix
i want to show about cops struggling
with their own internal biases
on netflix or amazon prime
and we can do it if we work hard enough
we can do it
it's it's absolutely impossible in the
real world but i
think if we had a show a good show where
is
there you your neighbor gets shot in
front of you and you go
[__] and you're angry
but then and you watch the show
and in the show there's a cop who was
gonna shoot your neighbor
and decided not to and then you go
they're not all bad
they're not all bad because i'm watching
a show
where a cops are being good on the show
that's the goal
and when is it it's interesting like the
decline of comp shows
and now all these bad cops are here
because they have no role models
you know like to have things like blue
bloods or whatever but i'm talking about
real good cop shows
hill street blues nypd blue homicide
life on the street law and order
these were shows where
even though the cops were racist and
corrupt
they were likeable and you realized that
you two were racist and corrupt
and that's what helped everybody through
it
that's what made it okay when you saw
these cops
struggle with their own biases
that you were like this is gonna be okay
keep going down look at all these i mean
these are these are
what a great can you bring up can you
bring up the opening sequence of new
york undercover please on youtube
opening sequence of new york undercover
it was on fox 5.
here's season one that is correct
put the music on
see this is when you know it's real
[Music]
these are the cops think of these cops
watching the news watch this
that's patty quinn she didn't shoot baby
diablo
she's tough but fair
dick wolf is the only person who cared
now go to nypd blue opening sequence
please
because this again was a great show
about good cops that were racist and
corrupt
but you liked them
here it is
we're talking we're solving bad people
around here we're trying to help the
good people
he was a racist but there's a black
[Music]
chief
you believed in the cops
[Music]
now yours did you go to chinatown you
see the dragon watch
where's the dragon show the darius
aries everyone was okay
bring it back bring it back
should i pitch that i got an idea
we got to do a cop show now but good
cops
it's hard out there for a pimp
and it ain't easy for a cop
it ain't easy for a cop
but every person i know who's
been a cop has been a criminal but
first very interesting
i don't know what the process is to get
selected
maybe lena waith will make something
years from now
where it's just cops skinning people
where cops are just boiling people in
pots and
eating them for dinner
perhaps i don't know
i'm how many days without cigarettes
that was so hard
you are a day six i'm it is so hard
i've never quit something that has been
this painful
because i quit cigarettes because i want
to die with the vaccine
[Music]
it's very difficult super hard
i've done it you have not you've been
smiling i have not you've smoked at
night in your house that's okay that's
your life
i just don't want you to die thank you
you're the lifeblood of the show
according to you know joe rogan
um but i do when i imitate him i have to
pretend like i'm chewing because that's
how you get locked up oh
come on but uh
i don't know it's been very difficult
but i'm doing i'm doing the right thing
there's a guy that i'm talking to that
kind of
that i do like so he has said i'm
holding you too that you won't
smoke which is good well we'll see but i
mean i
i i'm doing it for myself but it's also
you have a little extra motivation it's
nice too
you know what i mean keeps you're losing
your hair everybody is
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon you will keep
the hair that you have right now two out
of three men will experience some form
of hair loss by the time they're 35.
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern boldness there
are two
fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss keeps offers both
the generic versions of them that cost a
lot less money
okay everyone loves keeps it's got more
fast
five-star reviews than any of the
competition prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast
it's low cost treatment starts at ten
dollars per month they offer generic
versions
of all the big boy medications discreet
packaging and proven results
so you can keep your hair virtual
consultations and medication if you are
balding and it's starting to go and you
are go to keeps.com keps.com
tim dillon this is a way to keep your
hair good
right yeah you'll receive your first
month of treatment for free
great i love raycon wireless hair buds i
hate apple and i hate the apple ear pods
i love raycon they're offering 15
off all their products from my listeners
here's what you've got to do go to buy
raycon dot com slash tim
that's it if you like the podcast you
enjoy it you want to support us by
raycon dot com slash tim
15 off your entire recon order there's
no dangling wires or stems it's
wireless earpods they're amazing they've
got six hours of play time that's my
favorite things you can unplug for a
while you don't have to keep charging
them up
raycon makes great sound accessible to
everybody and wireless earbuds starting
at half the price of other premium
audio brands they're cheaper and they
work just as well if not
better okay it's super easy they're
offering 15
off i mean how can you lose again it's a
great gift for anyone
but um i will just
i love that during the read do not
mention that maybe not delivered
but i'll tell you right now it is uh it
is important to get these earpods i mean
i have them i like them i prefer them to
apple
you will too they're cheaper uh you can
buy them just in case you lose your
apple it's very good
perfect sounds good i'm in are you in
i'm in
buy recon dot com slash tim
oh yeah we got to do the afghanistan war
this
is this is this is a tribute to the
this is a tribute to the afghanistan war
my first war
and i never thought i'd feel this way
far as i'm concerned i'm glad i got
the chance to say
that i do believe i love you
taliban and if i should ever go
away the rocky
shows the skies are grey
your [__] kids have chained to your
bedpost i read that in an article
if you can remember me
keep smiling keep shining
21 years of
just war it's a just war
to help the pedophile warlords
we grow opium for vicodin
oxygen tastes so good
for sure especially when it's grown by
pedophile warlords
nothing grows but opium and boys
in afghanistan but
london wasn't even there
but who cares
you people have cool hair
[Music]
the pashtuns i think they were involved
i forget
[Music]
it went kaboom
and then we saw a group of
pedophiles warlords growing opium
instead
we said keep smiling
keep shining you're gonna have a
democracy
so you can
[Music]
for the drug addicts who live in our
country and lithium ion
we're gonna mine that because apple
needs it
to make so that our pedophiles can look
up
porn
it's about heroin and pedophilia
that's the entire foreign policy of our
country
it's about heroin and pedophilia
that's what aliens would say if they
looked at
history it's kind of amazing they'd go
all they ever did was [__] kids and get
high
they could have done so much other [__]
but they didn't
21 is a
[Music]
never even happened
the towers are still there they are
given vaccines in them now
for sure
[Music]
says we are not going there
anymore we're bringing the pedophile
to america you can come to america now
welcome bring your heroine we've got
boys
welcome to america says president biden
you can [__] kids and grow heroin here
ask everyone their pronouns it's been 21
years
of creating chaos in hell for financial
gain
thank you for everything we love you
and we hope you love us here's to 21
more years
of hell
take that pill it'll make you feel
better
and don't worry we'll be back we always
come back
we'll be back but until we do
we love you so that's our
that's our um that is our uh
uh montage in our tribute to uh
afghanistan and a just and beautiful war
so we hope that you have enjoyed the
afghanistan war as much as we have
and we're proud that
for you know since i've started the show
the afghanistan war has been
a sponsor and we're gonna have to find a
new war
to sponsor our show but what are you
gonna do
all right folks good luck at the if you
see a cop
out there god
i mean just don't do anything don't make
any affirmative
glasses movements just as you say a
female cop is like woof
good luck they'll be fine i'm sure
she'll be kim potter i'm sure isn't
i'm sure she's not indicative of what
else is going on i'm sure she's uh i'm
shirts
i'm sure it's an isolated event um
yeah gonna be touring more in the summer
we need these clubs to start opening up
the capacity
we can't comics can't keep doing eight
or ten shows for 25 of the audience like
we need these shows to start opening up
it's a little absurd right now
and uh we're hoping that by july or
august we're getting some full rooms in
there and really before that
half the country's vaccinated it's time
to move on with this [__]
uh the the idea that we could just you
know keep the 30 in these clouds i mean
it's like absurd
uh we need to we need to start opening
these rooms up the governors of these
states
are going to have to be become a little
less tyrannical i mean new york city now
has
50 people allowed they've got 50 people
letting in a curfew of 11 pm because
kovid
comes out at night guys what are we
doing
but again we'll see what happens but
uh we wish everyone the best and then
hopefully we'll get to go to afghanistan
and broadcast
from afghanistan that's my hope that's
my dream
um but until that day we'll just have to
get shot here in america you know
and listen we hope david dobrik comes
back too and i hope he's
i'll be do you know and this is
literally
he's he's said things are so bad cause i
i know people in his camp
things are so bad for him he's thinking
about becoming a cop
that's how bad it's getting is that he's
thinking of becoming a cop
this is from people that know him well
so
[Music]
you know he was doing a prank video i
saw the other day where he was injecting
a
a dog with the johnson johnson vaccine
and he was yelling at it now clot [__]
so that's again he's
trying he's coming back the whole
johnson johnson vaccine is actually just
an elk
prank the milk boys and elk boys
uh posed a scientist at johnson and
johnson
and came up with entire vaccines it was
they kind of got us
they kind of got us who do you think
wins jake paul or ben askren
jake paul interesting i'm gonna say that
too
i'm gonna say that too celebrity boxing
match ready
here we go lizzo versus kim potter
give the people what they want i take
lizzo on that
i do too i do
too i don't know you're excited about
your wedding
no one else is
i'm kidding we're very excited about it
be fun huh it's gonna be a good time
good you have a whole wedding party
there
and you chose i'm not in it but you
chose because you hate gay people
you chose all the other people to be in
it
oh you're talking about my gruesome yeah
do you do you want to be in it i feel
like you did i don't even want to go to
the thing
i really don't want to go to this i felt
like it would have been rude years ago
to have asked you
i mean it's rude now to ask me to go
to hang out with these people
i mean this is like i mean i imagine
this is just going to be everybody
there's a kim potter
at this wedding am i wrong to think
about that i mean
between q and kim potter i mean
you think they're go the nic
the nickname little baby diablo is gonna
be talked about five times
on that buffet line you know they called
him little homicide
they called him baby diablo that's what
they called him
you know jesus christ coming back to
fight babe diablo
i mean this is what it's going to be do
you have to say anything like people you
have to wear shoes and stuff
no i'm my man i'm not trying to be rude
but do you like
do people do people know they have to do
people know they have to wear shoes and
everything
i mean i'm asking what is the net worth
at this wedding
of the 60 people there the net worth is
going to be other than your friend's
family
the people that uh where are in dental
work what's the net worth of this
i think 60 people that tell me if i'm
being rude
and i don't want to be rude i'm never
rude this is what i believe
net worth of the 60 people liquid cash
we're talking about
let's let's take your friend's family
out he they're all coming right
let's remove them because they have
money even
that though if we like i'm think
i'm thinking like net worth
per person at this wedding is 25 000
yeah yeah let's let's let's go about
there
per person 25 000. i can think of 12
people off the top of my head that have
been unemployed for like a very long
time
right it's correct yeah
sean will be a lot of interesting people
to talk to
now these are people can you guys gotta
get up the scene from gummo outside of
the dairy queen please
because this is what i imagine gummo
dairy queen scene
because this is what i imagine [__]
come on gummo sometimes harmony korean
stuff's hard to why youtube
it's a great pin to this episode
um is that it that's the tap scene no no
no no this is
oh no that's the outsiders
there's a scene it's the albino maybe
google gamma albino albino scene
yes yes here we go okay so this is ben's
wedding if i could
uh this is ben's wedding okay okay let
me full screen this
because they're hot they're gonna be
happy i have a good personality
i have blonde hair blue eyes
i'm 135 pounds
and i'm four foot ten and a half
i have very light skin i am
considered what you would call an albino
i like men that are very sensitive
that will sit down and watch a
good movie with me won't hit on me
or love me for me i like humanity to
have
blonde hair blue eyes
or black or brown hair
actually the eyes it really doesn't
matter
my favorite movie stars are pamela
anderson
and patrick swayze patrick swayze is
sexy
he's good looking i love that man to
death
i would pay money to touch him
so this is going to be ben's i was born
without any toes on my feet at all
i would pick up things with the balls of
my feet instead of my toes
i had i had trouble walking on my feet
now that i mean not to be rude
but is that a good primer for what i
should expect it's not bad
yeah that's a decent primer you're there
for what
what i should expect at your wedding
yeah
and then your friend's family they have
money right who travis
yeah we don't want to say names on the
show whose family's not coming
oh they're not no no no see they won't
even be associated with it no
they don't they that did you invite them
no no
it's very small it's very small so
there's not even there wouldn't be space
for them
and they'd feel uncomfortable if they
went no they would love to come but we
just don't have enough space but just it
would be
would they be disturbed by like the
amount of people
like you know without shoes
would they notice it i'm not saying that
would they like notice it would they go
i thought because it's in the field
right and i feel like people are just
gonna be running around like
this is not what i think is gonna happen
it's a bunch of shoeless people being
like
take me have you ever seen the last
scene in powder
get the final scene of powder up this is
what i imagine every
wedding guest we'll be doing at ben's
wedding and then we'll get out of here
because we've gone long and i gotta go
uh right here yeah this is this is
this is what i believe everywhere okay
speed this up a little bit cause we i
don't want to do it
yeah right here yeah it's fine this is i
believe what ben's wedding will be
this is gonna be better yes this is
this is everybody at ben's wedding
this is
[Music]
and that's it we now pronounce your man
and wife
[Music]
all right are they are they are you even
gonna have like a wedding cake or you're
just gonna
have like kinda like safeway cookies or
something agb cookies
there will be a wedding cake bluebell
ice cream really
give me and chase something to eat while
we sit there alone and hope to die
what um we seated you with my family by
the way so you're watching
my mom and dad i'm very excited thank
you
that's very sweet that is very sweet
my mom will just ask you a lot of
questions about like joe rogan and stuff
well i'll i'll answer them pretty
honestly and i'll say uh
you're asking about something that you
know
that this show we don't think much about
you know no she can she can i'll answer
all the questions i'm very polite man
so who's at that table it's uh my dad my
mom
you i think my sister
okay and bronco bill okay as you call
them
and uh you and then devin and ida will
be at that time
oh phenomenal well lucky your parents
was just lucky for your parents huh two
great minds
that can really enjoy
um where's cole
cole will sit with my brother at a
different table
interesting with some people he knows
fair enough there's like
there's only like seven tables so we had
to like be strategic
i want to have a wedding to upstage this
but i can't
i don't i'm not gonna like no one wants
to marry me but still
i wanna upstate like i wanna have a
crazy but here's the question
do i have to have a partner to get to
throw a wedding
[Laughter]
could i just anger you and your wife
could i marry myself
what if i threw like an incredibly
incredibly luxurious absurd wedding the
week after yours to just marry myself
that would be amazing i think you could
marry yourself
i guess you could yeah because your dad
has the same name as you right
yes there you go what does that mean
well you could just
act like you have like two different
socials but you're really just marrying
yourself you know what i mean well i
wouldn't believe
it i'm allowed to marry myself
all right hold on
oh my it's my realtor
that was my realtor there's a [__]
problem at the house the septic tank is
overflowing with
[__] so uh i'm still buying the house
but uh
they opened the septic tank the other
day and it was just smelled of 30 years
of [__]
and it thing's 36 years old and it's
just buckling it's just
overflowing with [__] so
so good but you know i'm excited about
this wedding and i think sometimes
you're angry at me
why because i'm i'm poking fun and i'm
not being serious
i don't care weddings are dumb
they're not dumb they're not dumb
i am i am an entertainer and i think
sometimes you internalize these things
and you get angry with me because i'm
i'm making a joke i'm excited
i think the wedding's going to be lovely
i don't need i'm not
we're not going i don't need
people to recite the whole alphabet
that's not what we're doing here we're
trying to love people for who they are
do you understand i don't mind
port-a-potties
i don't mind none of that matters to me
i love you and i want you to be happy
thank you
you know what i mean doesn't matter i
want
how many people are coming that are like
like friends of yours that i haven't met
that'll be interesting to me because i
i only met one friend of yours maybe
seven
cause there's there's people out there
that i just did i don't know that are
friends of yours
yeah from my past yeah like six people
maybe five people
interesting yeah the next week i will
have
a 300 person wedding where i will marry
myself
and it will be spectacular
and you know who's going to be one of
the groomsmen yeah not you
not you dan carney
let's call let's let's see if dan will
be a
uh a group let's see if he'll be the
best man in my wedding while i'm
marrying myself
um again i'm not i'm not trying to
insult you
i think it's a good idea i think it's a
great idea
hey what's up dan quick you're on the
podcast right now uh ben is having a
wedding
on uh when is it ben saturday saturday
i'm going to throw a wedding the next
week after that
um to where i'm going to marry myself uh
to show ben and his wife that i have i
can
i'm i'm a little better position than
they are will you be the best man
at my wedding where i marry myself oh my
god i would love to
yes okay good because it will just be
you there will be no other groomsmen
because ben didn't ask me to be one of
his groomsmen which i understand because
he hates gay people uh and and his
family does and it'll just be a
gay hate festival but all right dan's
having high uh profile meetings today
i'm sorry dan get back to your meeting i
go back to your meetings dan
good luck
i will dan carney will be my best man
where i marry myself
but that's okay hey man it's totally
okay
that you didn't want me near your
wedding if i had asked you
to like be in my wedding you would have
like punched me i've never struck you
with my life
but i understand you wanted a crack
addict eventually you were gonna have a
crack addict
through the nuptials remember in the
beginning and i said that wasn't a good
idea
you're gonna have someone who's on crack
marry you
so but that's okay i hey man i get it
i get it it's like you know can't have a
[__] there i understand
i'm shocked i'm even invited i'm hey i'm
shocked i'm even invited i
i just hope that i can enjoy the
i hope that as we're all you know
reaching in an igloo cooler for our
drink
that um
that it'll be okay that's all when we
all reach down into that uh
igloo cooler for our drink
um and then go find our five guys
basket is five guys catering it no
it's not five guys who is it
it's a local austin barbecue spot oh oh
yeah oh
okay is it is it like is it like one
that i've heard of or is it like kind of
like a
what like a whataburger which i've also
heard of but is it like it's like fast
food though right
no no it's not fast food it's like real
barbecue well the sauce is being little
packets
i'm just curious
why are you why are you breathing heavy
because i've called you out for your
homophobia you know what michelle's
third wedding she did in and out and she
said people loved it
who gives a [__] what michelle did we're
not talking about michelle we're talking
about you and your refusal
to have a gay person at your wedding
i just hope the groomsmen have a good uh
podcast too
you can go you can go produce that
you can go produce that
you know but the reason you're
uncomfortable is because you're called
out now
and you this is this is this is
something you genuinely
you genuinely have really made me feel
horrible about who i am
as a person you know
every time that you don't
that you like every time you've not
asked me to be a groomsman
what you know what that is that's a
little diablo getting shot
you're shooting little diablo i am big
diablo
and you've hurt big homicide so
anyway i know that was you and your
wife's decision and
i wish you guys the best with your life
you know working at diners
and praying
there's nothing wrong with working at
diners i love diners nothing wrong with
it
oh i hope you don't feel there's
anything wrong with it
i hope you don't feel have you ever been
a short order cook
no i was head of take out head of
takeout yeah so i'd go back and like put
the food on the plates and like package
them and then come out
keep keep that keep that resume crisp
keep it chris i think my record was 140
orders and
six hours one who is it uh who's saying
who is doing the wedding is it pat
roberson
who'll be doing the wedding pat roberts
is it jerry falwell son
that guy who's raped a bunch of people
no i'm excited i'm excited all kidding
aside i'm excited about it i of course
don't want to go
but i have to go all right thank you for
going i know it's
nice to go it's nice to go
i was waiting for a gig to pop up maybe
or no
listen i'm gonna go i want to go and be
a second-class citizen
at the wedding that i paid for why
wouldn't i go
why wouldn't i go
anyway this is ben and the [__]
uh signing off
you know he'll take a fag's money but he
just won't
you know we got it it's okay
that's all right man just
i stand with little diablo and ben
stands with the cops
ben's a cop caller he's a white pig
okay me and andy know that's right you
and andy now walking arms
that's right you and andy know but i
stand
with the uh with the revolution
a little bit of fun and i can't wait for
my wedding recap
where i review the wedding
oh it's crazy michelle
hello hello michelle you're on the
podcast
really are you sure i am very sure
you're
you're you're speaking out your
microphone to half a million people or
more
do you have any message for the people
absolutely not um later love you bye
bye that's gross
what do you want me to do anyway
i wish you the best in everything you do
in your life
and i hope that
this is a turning point for you
you understand i hope you get a lot of
material out of the way
i hope you and travis have a great show
have a great podcast i'm very excited
when are you guys launching it
when we be launching the uh christ
almighty
ben and trump okay maybe she does have a
mess you changed your mind
yeah everyone just needs to dress up
more
that's it and you're and you're hardcore
anti-vaxx as well
i'm not interested i don't see them
hardcore
but i'm not interested okay fair enough
i wish people would start wearing slacks
and loafers and clean it up
okay all right well we love you thank
you
she said i wish people would start
wearing slacks and loafers and clean it
up she's not interested in the vaccine
fair enough fair enough but i do when is
the you in traffic do you have a name
for the show yet
why are you laughing i'm trying to help
you
trying to help you promote the show with
you and travis
they're gonna think it's real they're
gonna think i'm leaving the show
that i'm starting a new podcast there it
is they don't get it who cares what they
think
i just talked to you here i don't give a
[__] who's on the other end i have no
interest
truly no interest these people give me
suggestions for the show like i give a
[__]
what do you have who cares what do they
say who knows
whatever they say
scarce you say
i don't know what their thing is you
know
i'm just i'm just excited about your
future with travis
thank you as doing a really good show
and
you know i'm excited of dan carney's
future working at uh
i don't know uh a restaurant somewhere
between
cracker barrel and whatever that next
phase is red lobster yeah yeah
you're red lobster you do well at red
lobster no he'll
you know listen you guys are fine and
you know i'm just uh
i'm really holding everyone back is
really what i'm doing
i'm holding everyone back so i'm going
to marry myself in a ceremony which i
hope you'll attend
i will be there yeah it'll be a lake
house
i'm gonna invite everyone from your
wedding and pay them to come
okay okay and i'm gonna say
this is a real wedding i'm gonna go i
hope you enjoyed last week this is a
real wedding
and no i don't have a partner i'll be
marrying myself
but this is a real wedding and i'm glad
you guys all took off
you know because i know many of them
have to put in shift change requests
dairy queen
to come and just you know hey
i'm with it but anyway folks
i didn't know that was going gonna go on
a half hour but it did
and you know
high five love you no
come on nope nope ben is gays
go to ben's employer and let him know
how much he hates gay people that way he
gets fired from his job
two baddies employers andy no
andy knows not going to take any action
all right folks good luck with
everything kill yourselves goodbye